my first thought is we love you that's
weird but yes I agree I know we get it
we're weird but how did you like go from
being a dermatologist to like this kind
of phenomenon thing happening to you
because obviously you didn't set out to
be doctor pop no I did yeah I can't
pimple popper yeah there you go
I mean I've been I've been in practice
since 2004 but really about four years
ago I decided you know what let me start
an Instagram page and post some things
about dermatology and early on I posted
a blackhead extraction video and I think
people like you guys you guys pay
attention wait a minute what is this and
I just post something and then look four
years later it's a TV show
I've got 3.5 million followers on
Instagram and 3.5 billion do you just
love the extraction I have really been
big into extraction for most of my life
both doing my own extraction and seeing
how things are extracted to know the
right way to extract many times can she
say the word extract no here's the thing
you're not grossed out right by anything
nothing grosses me out
like really nothing you're my people
yeah we are your views yeah because you
talked about the fact that I lay in bed
at night with the phone like right here
and I watched like so into it and you're
like right in my face you should we
gonna accept my husband we're weird we
get it I do anybody reach it and I'm
like oh I got it I'll get it
you know it's all because it's
satisfaction may be so good isn't this
very nice thing that's the thing that
was really kind of shocking I think its
closure you feel like you've something
you've put something back which you know
put things back in place yeah you mean
you feel happy for those people
especially on the show where you see
really really extravagant kind of pops
you know and now you get to see them
kind of put back to normal it makes you
feel good isn't that interesting that
something so gross can make you feel
good
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this